what does emdr stand for again
yeah so eye movement reprocessing and
desensitization
and that's the deal with ptsd yes and
i had ptsd effects too which is
partially why i was so
hedonistic was that from your
deployments or was it from women or was
it a combination of all that
deployments one could say a combination
from childhood too
but deployments really triggered it
where see violence was a solution to
problems for me
that was that was the thing and so you
could i mean you're not a violent guy
like i've
like i've known you for a while i've
i've spent hours with you in person
um okay um but but you know for but you
it was also years ago too during that
time when i was
like practically homeless and lived with
a friend banging all these girls going
out or whatever i wasn't an aggressive
or violent person
but if somebody were to be aggressive or
violence violent i would turn it on
to solve that problem and i ended up
getting a pretty serious bar
altercation actually after one of my
tours and um was facing felony charges
um i don't have any charges everything
was thrown out because they were the
aggressors and they were the people that
were
not not in the right but i put myself in
that scenario and it could have gone
badly for me
and i don't recommend that right and it
was after that i realized
holy crap man i'm not normal i have to
handle
some of the stuff but it wasn't until
that breakup though
which is almost like year and a half now
going to two years where i did the emdr
and you know i'm very skeptical about
things i thought it was going to be bs
or whatever
how did you come across it like did
somebody recommend it the community
actually okay one percent community this
is why the community is good because
people bring their resources to the
table
uh bobby from the community okay it
doesn't mind me yeah
drop it on i'll keep his last name out
of it yeah um he was like dude you got
to do this i'm like bro
that sounds i don't know
bob's solid guy you haven't you have not
heard bob's
like full story yet yeah yeah well i've
hung out with him i actually know
because he lives he when he's not in
thailand he lives
in michigan so um so so yeah
um and i had gotten i had gotten
certified
in hypnotherapy at that point and i only
got certified in because it was
interesting and i wanted to be able to
game women better
like that no no no uh altruistic motives
when i did some of these things
yeah i know pretty much everything guys
do is to get the girls
right right when i was in that pua
mindset that's exactly what it was
wrong mindset good though anyone who's
listening on to this and
pay attention don't do that but um um so
led to a lot of pain and suffering for
me too
but um but yeah i had the hypnotherapy i
knew what was bs
what wasn't because there's a lot of
things that get billed as hypnotherapy
there's
total bs nlp as well a lot of total bs
woo
magic thinking but then there's the good
stuff that actually is behavioral
modification
and mental fitness and mindset
modification so you can affect
the behaviors and this is what i do with
guys in a coaching sense after things
like breakups and stuff like that
so that they can get rid of the mental
baggage and the emotional baggage
faster so that they can make better
decisions for themselves
and i will say after that breakup even
though
that was the most painful breakup i ever
went through because i
i did have those high emotions high
feelings for her and there were a lot of
good aspects to her
but she was weighed down by mental
illness i hate to say it like that that
is what it is
and it's a sad scenario because she's
not going to be happy
she will struggle for the rest of her
life and when you we care about somebody
and you realize that they're going to
struggle for the rest of their life
because they don't even have the
self-awareness enough to get the help
they need
that's the big problem you know i always
say like you know how do alcoholics deal
with a drinking problem is first
recognize they have a drinking problem
but most of these women that
have these like strong
personality disorders as you're
describing them um they don't want to
work on them and it's like okay well
um i'm done here then you know i think
we're i think we need to move on it's
just a decision that you have to make as
a guy
um is that like do you s
do you uh consciously go through a
like right now with women um do you do
do you consciously remove problem women
from your life
based on the experiences that you've had
or do you still invite them into your
life
accidentally from time to time no now
now there's no um attraction
to problem women now i say it limits
because i'm my ltr
and then i have my i will have plates
that we'll bring in right
yeah and so um the plates i'm not so
worried about because i'm not vetting
them for long-term
um scenarios they're usually younger
um than my otr who's 29
so usually they're going to be you know
younger than
about 25 or younger right and they're
they're not at a point they're not
at a point in their lives or they're
looking for a relationship
um their hypergamy is telling them to
keep their options open
because they haven't hit that epiphany
stage yet and so
you know i'm not so worried if she is a
party girl or this that but if she's
toxic or outright toxic it would cause a
problem in my life yeah i bet that out
very quickly now
because i'm now averse to toxic women so
it's the opposite
through hypnotherapy emdr and and that
mental training i don't
because here's what happens guys find
themselves attracted to the same type of
toxic women toxic behaviors
because that's worked for them even
though it was miserable
right and so it's again that going back
to that behavior and that thing that's
worked
they're then trying to overcome
something they
actually they're used to overcoming
things interesting i talked to a friend
about addictions
because when you understand addictions
it helps you understand how guys get
attached to their itis
and stuff right gambling addiction is an
interesting one because there's no
substance substance involved
and what's interesting about gambling
addictions is they're not addicted to
the wind
the wind is almost anti-climatic
they're addicted to trying to overcome
the loss
they're addicted to this emotional
turmoil they're in when they keep
trying to fight this loss that's why
people keep going to the
lottery booths and get the scratch and
win tickets you see them all the time
right they're playing not to lose right
like they're addicted to planning not to
lose is what it is
that is what it is they're addicted to i
had a counselor once
uh tell me when it came to toxic women
it was very good actually not not all
psychologists or counselors are equal as
we know they're not all sean smith right
so um so he said you know you go you're
he goes you're incredibly capable um
your iq is high you're so capable of
everything but he's like
you you constantly are digging yourself
out of a grave
and then once you get out you go wow i
used all this capabilities to get out of
the situation
and now you're uncomfortable because
you're not you'll get another situation
so you jump in another grave and then
you dig yourself out again and that's
exactly
what a lot of men do that's that's the
pattern i was in and it was the emdr
stuff that got rid of the traumatic
thinking and that
that hold of that traumatic stuff was
now gone
and once that was gone i could re-uh
frame my mind through
uh self-hypnosis hypnotherapy and um
and medic you know medic self-hypnosis
hypnotherapy is like meditation
but it's guided that's the best in
visualization it's the best way to
describe it
and you put in put myself in a different
frame of mind and and i just don't
especially with
wouldn't have worked with hypnosis alone
but the mbr got rid of that
connotation that that desire for these
toxic
women and and so when when a girl like
has those bpd traits and stuff
i'm like i kind of laugh at it and
there's no but i'm like get away from me
you know what i mean i don't even want
you as a plate i don't want you in my
life i don't want you in my house
i don't want you having a cocktail with
my ltr i don't care what she looks like
you know what i mean and so amazing how
that happens when your man spoiled
sport for choice though right exactly